on the 21st of July in the first
consulship of Valentinian horrible
phenomena suddenly spread through the
entire extent of the world such as are
related to us neither in fable knowing
truthful history for a little after
daybreak preceded by heavy and repeated
thunder and lightning the whole of the
firm and solid earth was shaken and
trembled the sea with its rolling waves
was driven back and withdrew from the
land so that in the abyss of the deep
thus revealed men saw many kinds of sea
creatures stuck fast in the slime and
vast mountains and deep valleys which
nature the Creator had hidden in the
unplumbed depths then as one might well
believe first saw the beams of the Sun
hence many ships were stranded as if on
dry land and since many men roamed about
without fear and the little that
remained of the waters to gather fish
and similar things with their hands the
roaring sea resenting as it were this
forced retreat rose in its turn
and over the boiling Shoals he dashed
mightily upon islands and broad
stretches of the mainland and leveled
innumerable buildings in the cities and
where else they were found so that amid
the mad discord of the elements the
altered face of the earth revealed
marvellous sights for the great mass of
waters returning when it was least
expected killed many thousands of men by
drowning and by the swift recall of the
eddying tides a number of ships and
after the swelling of the wet elements
subsided was seen to have foundered and
lifeless bodies of shipwrecked persons
life floating on their backs or on their
faces other great ships driven by the
mad blasts landed on the tops of
buildings has happened at Alexandria and
some were driven almost two miles inland
like a laconian ship which I myself in
passing that way saw near the town of
muthoni yawning apart through long decay
you
you